Freunde es ist mal wieder soweit ich
muss mir einen Überblick verschaffen was
so neues auf dem bestellmarkt in Köln
los ist deshalb bestellen wir bei drei
Restaurants die noch keine Bewertung
haben ich habe dieses Video zwar öfters
gedreht aber vertraut mir ist es jedes
Mal eine Wundertüte weil im Prinzip
testen wir einfach drei neue Restaurants
die komplett geil oder komplett scheiße
sein können deshalb bleibt auf jeden
Fall dran und wir gucken direkt ohne
lange rum zu reden das ist so feines
gibt so ihr kennt den alten Spaß wir
gehen auf Restaurants filtern nach
Bewertung und dann scrollen wir uns die
Finger runter es war so lange bis die
schlecht bewerteten langsam verblassen
und die nicht bewerteten Restaurants
auftauchen falls ihr darauf warte dass
wir wieder mehr kochende Videos seid und
beruhigt da kommt bald was auf euch zu
der ein oder andere Video ist uns leider
geplatzt aber wir haben etwas Großes
geplant und jetzt sind die Bewertung Weg
zu hatten wir sogar schon mal irgendwie
ein Video dir die Birdy Köln Südbahnhof
authentische amerikanische Fried Chicken
Klassiker
Geheimnis wo es gutes Fried Chicken gibt
sage ich nicht unbedingt nein übrigens
wundert euch nicht hat mir die Haare
geschnitten ich fahre jetzt in Urlaub
nach diesem Video und dachte mir
probiere ich auch was neues aus wenn ich
die ganze Zeit keine Videos dreht geiles
chicken Sandwich und das sieht verdammt
geil aus gibt es soweit ich weiß nicht
in Köln deshalb müssen wir chicken
Sandwich bestellen bestellen wir einmal
einmal Veggie einmal Plan Base nee das
ist beides recht bestellen wir einmal
normal einmal Reggie es gibt noch
Classics classic tenders und face
chicken tenders und dann halt readcorn
sweet peppers Mini Penis nämlich sofort
ihr merkt der Laden gefällt mir auf
jeden Fall hoffentlich ist noch gut
OHZ außen knusprig in weiß das ist da
hast Du mich ja eigentlich schon bei aus
dem crunchy erstes Restaurant
hier drin haben wir
teletots das sind einfach so gepuffte
frittierte Kartoffeln dazu 10 € chicken
Sandwich also besser ist es gut und es
sieht aber sehr sehr gut aus alter
Schwede oh diese spicy callopien aus
und das hier wird das mit Fleisch sein
dass das vegetarische aber Leute
probieren wir uns durch ich muss einfach
anfangen mit diesem Tablet 2 das wollte
ich schon immer mal essen und jetzt kann
ich einfach bestellen bei mir in Köln
übelst geil ich weiß gar nicht wie das
schmeckt ich denke oder er wartet sowas
wie so ein Rest hier
Rösti ist gar nicht falsch das ist
einfach übelst fettig aber deshalb auch
übelst geil oh wie knusprig die
angekommen sind aber auch
sweet peppers
Sonntag sind wir immer beim Fußball und
danach kommt schon mal vor dass ich die
Woche dann abrunde mit irgendwie five
guys irgendwie einen Burger oder so ich
glaube das ist ein ganz klassischer
Kandidat für Sonntagabend und verbessert
mich wenn ich da falsch liege aber ich
würde denken dass das kein fertiges
frittierzeugs ist weil edeltods noch
sweet peppert kriegt man in der Metro
oder so also ich glaube das ist zu einem
gewissen Grad besonders was wir hier vor
uns haben so wie dieses Bilderbuch
schicken Sandwich Rochen ordentlich
chicken drauf schön angetoastet eine
schöne Soße Shredders was kann das zehn
Euro chicken Sandwich
die kurze Antwort ist einiges es ist
wirklich ordentlich crispy frittiert für
meinen Geschmack vielleicht sogar ein
bisschen zu drüber also es könnte ein
bisschen weniger crispy sein wenn es
dafür noch saftiger wäre aber die
Komposition von diesem geilen Bann was
schön buttrig schmeckt angepostet ist
der Soße die eine gewisse Schärfe mit
sich bringt es ist ein verdammt geiles
chicken Sandwich das hier ist die Veggie
Variante mit so schicken Fingers Land
Base um auch wieder schön Pickels drauf
ein in die Masse
gerade gesehen die Textur von diesem
plant Base chicken ist richtig geil
kommt sehr nah ans richtige chicken dran
hat fast ein geileren besser als das
andere weil das ein bisschen danke
frittiert war richtig richtig sexy ich
würde dem ersten Spot 8 einhalb von 10
geben die Snacks 10 von 10 die Burger
richtig geil bisschen Luft nach oben
einfach in der finalen Zusammenstellung
dass noch juice hier wird so aber was
für eine geile Entdeckung Leute so kann
es weitergehen warten wir auf Spot
Nummer 2 schauen wir uns nach dem
zweiten Restaurant und ich habe hier
schon eins ins Auge gefasst romanda
China Restaurant es sind die kleinen
Dinge die das Leben schmackhaft machen
bricht mich irgendwie an weil da oben
sind diese Udon Nudeln glaube ich ich
weiß nicht und dann ist wahrscheinlich
falsch aber auf jeden Fall so dicke
Nudeln das sieht spannend aus und wir
gucken mal was sie sagen super 92 klingt
erstmal fair sauerschaft mit
Hühnerfleisch Eiern und Gemüse ist
eigentlich schon fast günstig ne Salate
war Kamera 350 Spezialitäten des Hauses
Auberginen Pfanne Rindfleisch in scharf
Soße
am ehesten interessiert mich tatsächlich
Rindfleisch in schafsoße mit sojacamp
Chili und schwarzbunt vor allem 16,90
Euro wenn man sich überlegt dass diese
Suppe 92 kostet muss man eine riesen
Portion kriegen den wir rindfleischen
schafsauce gucken was kommt es ist
soweit unsere Bestellung Nummer 2 ist
angekommen Rindfleisch in schafsoße ich
bin sehr gespannt was uns erwartet ich
glaube auch wenn man sowas mal bestellt
wo nicht ganz klar ist was ich dahinter
verbirgt kann man einen Goldfund machen
schauen wir was uns hier erwartet
erstmal so eine klassische Reisbeilage
und hier ist das Rindfleisch siehst du
wie das Öl da oben schwimmt es sieht
aber gut aus aber andererseits 16,90 €
ist auch schon echt teuer ne wir haben
jede Menge Fleisch das erklärt auch den
Preis da sind die Sojasprossen drin dass
das Rindfleisch drin ich nehme mir mal
so ein bisschen von dem Rindfleisch
auf jeden Fall ein Geruch den ich nicht
so wirklich kenne probieren wir und
gucken wir wie scharfes vor allem ist
das hat auf jeden Fall eine gewisse
Schärfe das Rindfleisch ist auch schön
scharf und es hat auch so eine Aromatik
die ich gar nicht unbedingt kenne also
chinesische Küche wenn ich ziemlich
unbewandert muss ich sagen alles in
allem interessantes Gericht ich würde es
glaube ich aber nicht noch mal bestellen
weil irgendwas aber ich glaube das ist
in meinem Kopf ich gebe dem sechseinhalb
von zehn suchen wir jetzt nach dem
dritten Restaurant osteuropäische Küche
in vegetarisch und vegan aus der
europäische Küche da ist ja auch gerne
mal so die ist auch gerne deftig und so
die in vegetarischen vegan würde ich
gerne testen nehmen wir einmal die Bosch
vegane Variante des ukrainischen
Klassikers mit rote Beete Weißkohl
kartoffeln Möhren Tomaten Champignons
auf Wunsch serviert mit Schmand die
haben aber irgendwie Fans die Namen
misses Dampf misses Herz
mit Schokolade und Banane Blini mit
Quark und Rosinen geil wir nehmen
Schokolade und Banane aber wir brauchen
noch irgendeine Hauptspeise die nehmen
glaube ich
klassische russische Küche für
Vegetarier sojastreifen mit traditionell
Stroganoff Champignonsoße dazu
Grillgemüse und eine Beilage nach Wahl
und jetzt haben wir ein geiles Menü
Bosch Blini bei Stroganoff let's go
bestellen wir und dann sollte es gleich
bei uns sein ich habe hier einmal alles
was die osteuropäische Küche in
vegetarisch bzw sogar vegan zu bieten
hat einmal eine Bosch ich hoffe ich
spreche das richtig aus boah das riecht
verdammt gut gucken was wir sonst noch
haben mit Schokolade und Banane die tue
ich erstmal zur Seite hier drin haben
wir noch das Beef Stroganoff alter
Schwede sieht das geil aus in komplett
vegan das ist vegane Sahne die wir hier
drin haben wenn noch ein bisschen
erlädchen dazu und man
für unseren Tisch probieren wir zuerst
einmal die Bosch boah die ist richtig
schön ist ja auch glaube ich immer so
ein Sauerkraut oder zumindest so
eingelegtes Gemüse drin und es riecht
sehr gut probier erstmal nur die Suppe
ist auf jeden Fall eine Ecke süßer und
weniger herzhaft als ich das von früher
kenne ich hoffe ich habe es überhaupt
richtig in erinnerung das ist so eine
gewisse Säure hatte und zwar auf jeden
Fall sehr kräftig hier ist jetzt weniger
kräftig aber das kommt wahrscheinlich
auch bei deiner normalen Bosch aus dem
Fleisch so diese Kraft in der Brühe
nichtsdestotrotz auf jeden Fall ein
geiler neuer Geschmack den man so selten
bekommt dazu
jetzt sind wir auf jeden Fall näher dran
einmal kurz probieren an diesem
Paprikasalat grüne Paprika Tomate gelbe
Paprika rote Paprika schmeckt einfach
nur nach dem jeweiligen Gemüse das hier
ist wiederum sehr spannend das sogar
noch mit veganer Sahne und Soja
Geschnetzeltem probier mal nur das
Geschnetzelte mit der Soße mir fehlt
jetzt schon ein bisschen Salz aber von
der Textur her von der Cremigkeit sehr
geil das ist schon ein Essen wo man als
Zuschauer viel Fantasie braucht wenn man
es jetzt nicht irgendwie aus der
Kindheit kennt sondern schön cremig ne
vielleicht ist das wirklich gut finde
ich auch aber es ist da fehlt eine Ecke
Seite
ja ich finde die Grundlage geil ich
finde es auch spannend diese Gerichte in
vegetarisch zu essen kann man noch ein
bisschen die letzten Prozentpunkte
rauskitzeln würde ich sagen Leute
übrigens wir haben bisher von den
anderen beiden Spots auch alles schon
aufgegessen macht euch keine Sorgen es
wird hier nichts weggeworfen da gebe ich
euch mein Wort drauf die haben wir
einmal unsere Blini wunderschön
eingepackte Pakete Schoko Banane
natürlich eine altbekannte Kombination
durch das mal an so müssen sie sein sehr
schön
mit ordentlich Schokolade ich probiere
ich finde man merkt das ist schon auf
eine Art und Weise ein Restaurant
welches aufgemacht wurde nicht mit so
einer strikten Rechnung wie können wir
möglichst viel Geld verdienen sondern
wahrscheinlich haben die Betreiber eine
Passion diese osteuropäische Küche sind
vielleicht selbst vegetarisch und wollen
das einfach zugänglich machen und das
finde ich cool weil das sind spezielle
Gerichte das ist kein Standard Zeug das
ist nicht die x1000ste Pizzeria die
nichts neu macht sondern das ist schon
geil und die Blinis mit Schokolade geil
Freunde was für ein Abschluss für dieses
sehr sehr leckere Video ich glaube
zumindest bei dem ersten Sport werde ich
definitiv noch mal bestellen aber auch
der letzte war wirklich nicht schlecht
danke fürs zusehen wir sehen uns nach
meinem Urlaub wieder mit ein paar schöne
Videos direkt aus der Küche wo ich
frisch was für euch koche bis dahin
macht's gut ciao ciao ciao